winning the battle winning the war I
have lost many battles many of them and
they sucked and I would watch my enemies
to see what they're trying to do to me
I'm like okay that hurt that was good
good for you but then I'm like but
you're you just strengthened me but what
you just did there was an event one time
we're in Las Vegas you remember the
event we're across the street an enemy
of ours is having a convention okay the
entire convention I'm getting text
messages and all these names that
they're saying about us okay we're out
of we're a smaller company they're a
bigger company but I kept getting
recordings being said they just said
this from stage about you this person
said this about you that person said
this about you and next thing you know
my Instagram blew up with people saying
hey man everybody's talking about you
guys what are you guys doing over there
for this many people to talk about
you they must fear you right I saw a the
floodgates open of calls to me they won
the battle but then all of a sudden
we're getting the calls